so you you luke luke you mentioned uh
the uk but let's let's pull up the story
from fox ktvu real quick
coronavirus surge swamping hospitals
prompts indefinite
california lockdown all right they're
gonna they're gonna have to get specific
on that
what do you mean indefinite you mean
people are stuck in their homes forever
they say california's most densely
populated area continues to set new
death and hospitalization records
and will remain under strict stay home
orders for the foreseeable future
as another hospital filing coronavirus
hospital filling
coronavirus surge looms in mere weeks
public health officials said
l.a county which has recorded 40 percent
of all covet-19 deaths in the state
reported another 227 new deaths on
tuesday although the new daily record
included reporting from holiday backlogs
the country's public health department
also confirmed its highest number of
hospitalizations reported a day
at more than seven thousand people a
nearly one
thousand percent increase from two
months ago
california's top health official dr mark
galley
announced tuesday an extension of the
december 6 lockdown restrictions for the
county
and 22 others in southern california and
the agricultural san joaquin valley
the regions have about 60 percent of the
state's population of 40 million
and also have seen covet 19 surges since
thanksgiving holi since the thanksgiving
holiday
have that have left hospitals struggling
to find beds for emergency room and
intensive care unit patients
some hospitals have set up tents to hold
er patients and
one converted a disused cafeteria to
handle patients
so they're saying indefinite lockdown
all right the first thing is the
constitutional question
how do you do that that clearly violates
our rights as american citizens if
people choose
to go and assemble somewhere they have a
right to do so the constitution doesn't
say unless there's an emergency
but what authority they have to override
that but then the other here's the other
side of that coin
i mean they're giving us some crazy
numbers we got super coveted now
gavin newsom is saying we got the
mutated covet strain
shouldn't we be scared of these things
well we've been hearing about mutant
strains for a while now
first we heard it in the united kingdom
then we heard about it in south africa
then we heard about it in nigeria
but also in april of this year we heard
about 30 other different strains of the
coronavirus that that that happens i
think they're in in los angeles
personally facility speaking
i think they're just trying to make sure
people don't escape before they all get
taxed to death
and i think that's well done they're
trying to pass that law
where people get taxed even if they
leave the state
for uh years yeah that you're still
gonna have to because again
they've spent all their money and
they're in a huge deficit but i think
it's it's pretty clear now i
i think i don't know if you would agree
with me chris that these lockdowns are
kind of counter-intuitive
well they're they're club-ish and and
ham-fisted right so
here's what we've known for a long time
listen i'm i'm not averse to the idea
you say we don't want to swamp our
hospital systems that's not good right
motorcycle victims don't get the
treatment they need cancer patients
can't go in for treatment i get that and
real quick you're a doctor
you're a doctor you have a phd in yes in
a medical i went to duke university and
got a degree in pathology so okay all
right well tell us tell us what's going
on you're the expert
well if you're going to do a lockdown
first up here's what we know
if i was going to draw a chart for you i
would say you'd say okay who gets hit by
this who dies
you have an exponentially increasing
risk of death by age
so if you were going to do a lockdown
you'd say we're going to lock down the
old people right not the young people
the chance of dying from this if you're
under the age of 30
is minuscule really really tiny
so i think something a lockdown is
everybody
why is it everybody you would think that
it somewhere along the way you could say
well let's be clever about this let's
take the people with comorbidities let's
take the people who are
immunocompromised let's take the elderly
and let's keep them safe right that
would be part one if you're just on the
subject of lockdowns which isn't even
getting me on the idea
that we still to this day the nih has
zero
outpatient treatments identified they
just say go home and if you feel worse
come back and if it's bad enough we'll
put you in the hospital that is
literally
as of this morning what was on the nh
website there's actually a good friend
of mine
uh got sick recently i was talking to
him on the phone and they told me that
they went to the doctor doctor told me
they had covered and just go home and
deal with it yep
and they were like uh i don't think i
have covid
like you know they thought they had
strep throat something you know
they've had before and they needed
antibiotics for but the doctor said no
no
we're gonna treat it as covey just go
home and if you get worse then you know
call back
and that was it that's it that's
standard of care right now and it and
it's criminal as far as i'm concerned
because there are things that people can
do
so for a quick example we've known since
march vitamin d
it's really more of a hormone but
vitamin d the stuff you get if you go
out into the sun
right which is hard to do in a lockdown
when you're all stuck inside right but
that stuff alone we've had a spanish
study
which showed that of people who were in
critical condition they measured their
blood levels and they said how much
vitamin d do they have
so they discovered that people with
lower than 17 nanograms per ml of
vitamin d in their blood were 80 percent
of their critical covid patients
nobody with vitamin d above 21 nanograms
per mil
was even showing up in their critical
icu so they said wow let's do a study
and they started giving this to people
when they showed up at the hospital and
they cut deaths and they cut
hospitalizations just vitamin d and i
want to make one thing absolutely clear
this is we're not here to give anybody
medical advice you know talk to your
doctor
because you're going to hear a lot of
things from a lot of people in a lot of
different places
we've we've got serious criticism of dr
fauci now because he's changed his
numbers on on
herd immunity he was the one who
initially said you know don't wear masks
so look i'm i'm i'm here to say this i
don't care if you're
left right up down whatever it's your
doctor who knows what's best for you so
take that seriously
and we'll give our opinions yeah and do
your own research do your own homework i
mean i
personally decided to take vitamin d
myself but i know there's a chance of
taking too much of it as well exactly
and i know that you should also get your
blood
tested to make sure that your levels are
normal and not
either too low or too high even if it's
too high
it could be dangerous for you and one of
the one of the big issues i think we see
that
sort of exacerbates a lot of censorship
is that
people will go online and they'll learn
about something maybe even like vitamin
d and then they might take too much
that's why i gotta talk to your doctor
your doctor is going to know better than
we will about you so but anyway i
digress well even dr fauci admitted
finally that he's taking vitamin d on
his own right and he but he said that to
jennifer garner so he might have been a
little star struck he was on her blog
vlog right and she said what are you
taking he said well i'm taking vitamin d
you know and so here's the you know the
peop the person that people are
nominally looking to the most
right yeah what is the downside for
somebody like that to say here's what
i'm doing
you might consider it too but talk to
your doctor yeah and well i i i want to
make sure i pull this up
dr fauci from cnbc.com is recommending
vitamin d
so there you go yeah he could have done
that in march he could have done that
would have been nice this was september
you know the scary thing is there hasn't
been a conversation about
health there hasn't been a conversation
about vitamins about diets about
exercise about sleep about stress about
exercise
there hasn't been real conversations
about things that actually matter that
will have a huge tremendous effect on
what we're dealing with right now that's
fat shaming
okay yeah okay and and abilistic i made
a video about the fatties
uh today not people are going to like
that but i think it's important to bring
up the reality of the situation so
people
understand what they're getting them
it's a co-morbidity yes obesity was a
big factor
and obesity is dramatically going up in
the united states
some would say as a byproduct of the
industry buying off the government and
of course implementing a lot of policies
that have been very hurtful
and it's kind of strange that now a
government that absolutely had what
industry though i mean
we're talking about industries like
monsanto and the fast food industry and
the sugar industry when you look at
their impact
on the market when you look at their
impact on human life you see a huge
i would say in my opinion a detrimental
impact that should be addressed
should be should be uh they should be
held accountable for but the larger
point that i'm
trying to kind of point to and make here
is that
we're kind of left in the dark and and
we don't know
what to do because when you even talk
about this stuff you risk
getting censored and banned which is
absolutely ridiculous and you know why
the way the the the censorship works
it's not like there's a doctor at
youtube who's got like a checklist of
the appropriate response
cdc guidelines going like what did he
talk about he talked about that's okay
we approve of that we prove it no it's
like some 20 year old dude going like
he's talking about medicine like he's
not a doctor i'm going to ban this
even when you are a doctor even doctors
are getting banned yeah
didn't you you get hit or something like
that i did i i got a youtube strike
and um and you're you're not a medical
are you a medical doctor no you're not
no
but you have a doctor but you have a
doctorate in pathology yeah and i'm i'm
eminently qualified to read reports and
analyze them but
in this case all i was doing there was a
senate testimony of a board-certified
doctor who's in critical care dr corey
he was giving senate testimony basically
that this the headline of it is
i can't keep doing this anymore those
are his words and he what he
what he meant was he couldn't watch
people come into his critical care
pulmonary center and die
because he knew they didn't have to
because he'd seen all this data all this
data coming in from all over the world
saying there are
things we can do and that was his
testimony so i thought well let me
review that for people and i that's all
i did i reviewed
a board-certified doctor's testimony but
that was deemed medical disinformation
i think there's a if i were to if i were
to take like a simple
uh like if i was to assume the simple
reason as to why
youtube is so and incredibly sensorious
is that they're scared of the media
because when this all started when the
wall street journal smeared pewdiepie
then all of a sudden their advertisers
just dropped off and youtube already is
burning a hole in the pocket of google
losing money
so they're just like whatever the media
says will do
and so you get activists in media who
will find
any reason to accuse you of wrongdoing
and they they've even removed
rand paul was giving a speech on the
senate floor on c-span youtube billy did
it
youtube took the video down because oh
no we can't have that they're they're
more worried about the negative public
perception from media companies
than allowing people to have this
conversation
to hear this testimony was the doc dr
corey said his name was
yeah dr corey he was testifying to
congress
and you that that's that's not that's
not that's not allowed anymore i guess
so we we we're we're you know i kind of
feel like it's like i don't know if you
guys ever see one of those cartoons
where they're
they're on a mountain side like driving
on a road along a cliff and then the car
is like turning and the wheels are on
the edge
and so that's what we're kind of getting
into getting into here but you know hey
whatever so be it
well you saw rand paul's dad ron paul
got a ding he got a
youtube strike really well it's uh i'm
sorry it's uh uh
ron paul's son rand paul ron paul's the
original i know ron paul the original
yeah yes the original talk about covid
he he covered a trump rally and he also
got dinged with medical disinformation
as the ding
he's literally a doctor yeah i know he
was an ob gyn right yeah i love
it what and it's it's crazy man
breitbart
filmed this is amazing breitbart was
rated
was certified as uh credible by
newsguard which is like a microsoft
funded you know
news credibility rating system but then
they filmed a press conference
put on by a republican representative
and some doctors and that was deemed
enough to
strike them down as not credible they
didn't even say anything
they just filmed other people talking at
the capitol with a politician but but
this is this is the bigger problem here
that we
really need to realize the official line
that they're going with keeps
flip-flopping every week
whether it's the world health
organization or the cdc they literally
contradict themselves
so many times and haven't come out with
any concrete
legitimate information that has been
consistent i don't know about you but
i have a very hard time thinking that a
government that never gave a damn about
my health
somehow now is it's their number one
priority i think there's a lot of room
to be skeptical here
but again there's no consistency here we
don't know what the official line is
because it keeps changing
i don't think the government cares about
anything i i think there's one thing
collectively that's on the minds of
politicians and bureaucrats it's
what will i do that's over the line that
results in torches and pitchforks
that's the thing right that's the like
it's are the people going to protest and
rabble because protests
mostly i'll tell you this nonviolence of
disobedience works but
i don't think they care anymore because
the way i described it uh you know
earlier this year you're
only allowed to say bad things there's
no conversation where we can be like hey
we have good news a doctor
said these things it's positive it's
it's upbeat it's it's a lighting into
the tunnel they ban you for it
they ban you for it you talk about this
country brought up these treatments oh
trump is crazy
he's wrong he's lying i would say i
could say something like
uh you know techcrunch reported that
zpac you know uh
hydroxychloroquine was showing promising
results in a french study and then a
smear piece comes out claiming
you know using using twisted uh framing
timpool claims that studies prove blah
blah but that's not true
even though it's like you know they'll
try and make sure you can't say anything
positive
so what ends up happening is all the
news that comes out is super covet is
here
hospitals are overrun everyone's you
know sick and dying it's getting worse
it's worse it's worse it's worse
and so then everyone just keeps getting
more and more scared
and that results in the snowball rolling
down the hill of the story only going
crazier and crazier
because imagine this right now what we
know
is there are many hospitals that are
being overrun we see the photos and the
videos of the nurses there
and they're like their faces and they're
like the marks on their face from the
ppe and they're tired and they're
beating their hair's all messed up
most hospitals it's my understanding are
actually okay
there's tons of videos of hospitals that
have not been you know overrun and
that's because hot spots are centralized
in certain areas
but we're not getting video after video
after video of hospitals that are okay
we're getting video after video after
video of hospitals they're doing worse
and then we're getting videos of nurses
dancing i guess that's kind of the
positive i suppose
glad they have time for that right yeah
yeah yeah but
the main point i'm trying to make is if
the only thing you ever hear and are
allowed to hear
is that things are getting worse you'll
you you don't actually know
like there's no balance to this
conversation are we going
is there is there a chance for optimism
can't tell you that because we'll be
censored if we do
that's where we're at yeah and as a
scientist this actually bothers me a lot
this whole idea that there is
a central body that there's an
agreed-upon set of facts that we know we
don't know crap
about this at this point in time right
so here what we know it's a novel
corona i can i even say this you know
yeah yeah just yeah i can i can say that
word
virus chronovirus i can do that let's
say that yes i mean
look if we get banned whatever so so
it's novel which means we have to try
some things right and
the whole thing about the dr corey in
his testimony he said look
we don't need the latest whiz-bang stuff
out of farm but that would be great but
we have a hundred years of medical and
medicine development and we have things
that work and by the way we try things
all the time
off label we try things in for other
things and they work all the time in
fact
we do all sorts of off-label stuff
already with kids you give them like you
know ssris and all that stuff that's off
label right don't
aren't there like medications that have
a side effect of weight loss that they
prescribe to people to lose weight
like is there stuff like that too that's
off label right yeah
and and everything has a side effect you
know everything water
take too much you have a side effect but
i would just think that at some point
this whole idea
we can't have that positive news isn't
the nation just like ready for some of
that relief
wouldn't they be just wouldn't everybody
just be kicking their heels up if we
said
we can there's something that some
doctors are saying is really effective
and by the way there's a lot of them
that's better than go home and come back
to the hospital if you feel worse
if it bleeds it leads so lady just
pulled this up this is from fortune.com
u.s
news coverage of covet has been more
negative than in other countries
researchers find
that so and that's a fact like you
mentioned you got you took you got a a
strike
right on youtube and and uh ron paul did
as well and you
are a a phd in a pathologist and
rand paul is literally a doctor well i
should say he's retired
but uh man how crazy is that so
i started reporting again january 23rd
within a couple of weeks maybe a week
and a half or so my wiki page which had
been up for over a decade got yanked
got taken down and the complaint was
that i was talking about things that was
that were
out of my wheelhouse that i had no
authority that in fact i wasn't a
practicing scientist and all this stuff
now i'm a published scientist
and and it's true i've been doing other
things besides you know conducting
science for a while
but that doesn't invalidate the training
or the degree or what i know right they
have
the papers that you've gotten published
in scientific journals been invalidated
or
don't move so it's all it's all
currently standing science it is yes
well this happens in many different
instances in many different kind of
areas for me personally they got me
because i didn't believe in the russian
collusion
after donald trump's victory when he
first won the presidency
and they de-listed me they de-personed
me on wikipedia and said that this is a
person that shouldn't even be mentioned
or referenced no matter what he does no
matter what news he's
trying so hard just to give yourself
i'll tell you there there's been
uh a lot of attempts at
somehow finding a way to smear me
because i'm so i'm i'm i'm as if
i'm like fairly boring you know tepid
commentary for the most part
but uh there was an article i read from
fox business about seth rich
and then there was a statement from
kitten.com they claimed that by talking
about it and arguing that it wasn't
definitive
i was pushing a conspiracy theory and
then nbc writes that and
airs on tv i'm a conspiracy theorist
and then all of a sudden a bunch of
other outlets just repeat it without any
basis any fact checking any sourcing at
all
even though i'm the one who's constantly
reigning on all these pr on all the
parades of these people saying it's
probably not true outcomes razor simple
solution
and i don't believe in any of this stuff
doesn't matter they need to find a way
to discredit you
and take you down i'm surprised that
right deleted your wikipedia page that's
that's bold that's one way to do it
because no one's i think one of the
issues is who's gonna write negative
things about you and what's their
grounds to do it
right you're you're a published
scientist giving your thoughts and
opinions
quick get rid of them because if they
can't smear you and find a way to do it
they have to just get rid of you right
right so i wasn't big enough to
to not be gotten rid of right you have
to be big enough so that it makes too
much of a stink you know so i think
already by early february this means
that there was a very serious attempt at
message control
and my view was remember at the time
like new york
times watching posts are all saying oh
it's just the flu it's no worse than the
flu and i was like no this is totally
different here's some of the the
virology behind it this thing has got a
lot of keys into the human locks
and it's a little bizarre and i was
saying we need to take this really
seriously
and at the time i was totally in
conflict with the who because they were
saying
well we shouldn't shut down travel and
that's i was just reading their own
pandemic handbook that's what i was
sourcing from and i was saying no that's
actually step
one you you stop travel of course you do
even george washington when he was
facing a huge outbreak of smallpox
first thing he did was he stopped people
traveling to and from his army
right didn't he write letters telling
people to get vaccinated too
they were like they had some like that
little stick thing that they gave yeah
yeah there was like a letter going
around where george washington was
apparently like
get the smallpox vaccine that was my
first moment i'm a scientist i'm trying
to share data
i think this is interesting it could
help people get prepared you know i was
telling people get ppe
n95 mass way before they got sold out
all that but then i'm confused i'm like
how is the who getting like its own
handbook for this wrong
and then my wikipedia page gets taken
down and then i've just run
my youtube subscriber count was just
skyrocketing and it leveled off the day
i mentioned hydroxychloroquine it's been
literally plus or minus 1000
for eight months it's just it's just
flat it's 365
000 that's the just flat works man yep
well we also have to remember during
that specific time it wasn't just the
world health organization going against
their own guidelines
it was also many politicians in the
mainstream media saying it's xenophobic
to stop travel yes that it's racist to
stop traveling
and then politicians told you to go to
the chinese day parade and to go
celebrate
to show that everyone's not racist come
on down to chinatown yeah be racist
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you